sensoren begegnen uns überall sie bilden
nicht nur einen essenziellen bestandteil
alltäglicher technologien sondern auch
eines der grundlegendsten elemente
moderner wissenschaft ohne sensoren wäre
die erforschung von winzig kleinen
zellen bis hin zu gigantischen
kosmischen ereignissen schließlich
einfach nicht möglich kein mensch hätte
jemals ohne die richtigen sensoren den
mond betreten oder die existenz der
gravitationswellen beweisen können
dieser drang zu einer immer genauere
messung kleinster änderungen in unserer
umgebung treibt unsere sensoren
technologien immer weiter und die wir
bereits bei computern und der
kryptographie feststellen konnten bewegt
sich dieser fortschritt auch bei der
sensorik in richtung quantenmechanik in
der heutigen folge meiner quanten serie
geht es deshalb um die passende benannte
quanten sensorik
ein guter sensor erfüllt die folgenden
drei kriterien erstens er muss sensitive
gegenüber genau der eigenschaft sein die
gemessen werden soll
zweitens er muss in sensitive gegenüber
allen anderen eigenschaften seien die
bei der messung auftreten können und
drittens er darf die gemessenen
eigenschaft nicht beeinflussen so ein
sensor nimmt die form eines geräts an
dass die gemessenen eigenschaft in ein
entsprechendes elektrisches signal
umwandeln kann
dieses elektrische signal können wir
dann in andere technologien wie zum
beispiel einen computer chip
weiterleiten
zum beispiel wird aus den informationen
der sensoren einer waage ein gewicht
berechnet welches dann wiederum auf
einem display sichtbar wird okay aber
wie genau kommt da jetzt die
quantenmechanik ins spiel können wir mit
ihr noch präzisere sensoren bauen
[Musik]
weil sie es noch nicht gesehen habt dann
solltet ihr jetzt hier unbedingt erst
mal mein video zur quantenmechanik
anschauen da kamen wir nämlich zum
schluss das quantenmechanische
überlagerung zustände extrem sensitive
gegenüber ihrer umwelt sind kleinste
störungen in der umgebung können eine
zustands änderung oder eine sogenannte
zustands reduktion hervorrufen
zusammengefasst heißt das einfach dass
sich die quantenteilchen für einen der
vielen sich überlagernden zustände
entscheiden
dass aber auch die verschränkung von
quantenteilchen bietet neue
möglichkeiten die ein herkömmlicher
sensorik bisher überhaupt nicht denkbar
waren während der quantenverschränkung
bilden mehrere teilchen ein gesamtsystem
wobei ein teilchen die möglichen
zustände alle anderen teilchen im system
beeinflussen kann
ändert man den zustand eines
verschränkten teilchen es dann ändern
alle anderen teilchen im verschränkten
system ebenfalls ihren zustand so
zumindest die theorie in der quanten
sensorik werden also teilchen verwendet
aus denen wir informationen gewinnen
können sobald sie einem spezifischen
ereignis zu nahe kommen und diese
teilchen sind wegen der quantenmechanik
extrem sensibel gegenüber diesen
ereignissen
genau diese tatsache resultiert aber
auch im größten problemen der quanten
sensorik die teilchen sind zwar extrem
gut darin kleinste ereignisse
wahrzunehmen
gleichzeitig aber auch einfach
unheimlich anfällig für alles andere in
ihrer umgebung
deshalb versuchen heutzutage die meisten
wissenschaftler dieses sogenannte konnte
das quantenrauschen zu entfernen
in der metrologie also der wissenschaft
präziser messtechnik ermöglicht gerade
die quantenmechanische verschränkung
messungen weit jenseits der klassischen
genauigkeit und das weil man mit ihr das
quantenrauschen drastisch reduzieren
kann
forscher am ende schafften das bereits
2015 in einem versuch bei dem zwei
verschränkte photonen strahlen verwendet
wurden
hierbei wurde einer normal zu
gewöhnlichen informationsvermittlung
durch ein glasfaserkabel geschickt der
andere wurde jedoch einfach nur in die
umgebung projiziert beide dieser
photonen strahlen wurden gleichermaßen
durch das rauschen in der umgebung
beeinflusst doch nur einer von beiden
trug die tatsächlich übertragenen
informationen der andere strahl lieferte
lediglich eine art abbild des rauschens
in der umgebung mit diesen zusätzlichen
daten zum quantenrauschen konnte man
dann die störungen in den eigentlichen
informationen deutlich reduzieren
messungen die sonst selbst im
quantenmechanischen rauschen untergehen
würden können so erst wirklich zum
vorschein kommen diese prinzipien können
wir also wie bereits im video zur
quantentechnologie erwähnt für die
sensorik nutzen besonders essentielle
messgrößen wie zeit beschleunigung oder
elektrizität aber auch gravitation oder
magnetismus lassen sich mit der
quantenmechanik ziemlich exakt bemessen
die wahrnehmung der gravitationswellen
wäre zum beispiel niemals in unserer
sensorik zum vorschein gekommen hätte
man das rauschen nicht verringern können
es geht schließlich darum unvorstellbar
geringe schwankungen in den messungen im
lego aufzunehmen ok ziemlich cool aber
gibt es auch anwendungsgebiete die für
unseren alltag nützlich sind
[Musik]
mitunter einer der wichtigsten
anwendungsgebiete dieser
quantentechnologie ist das global
positioning system das gps die
satelliten die für das gps um die erde
fliegen haben alle extrem genaue uhren
an bord nämlich atomuhren diese uhren
berechnen die aktuelle uhrzeit mit hilfe
der quantenmechanischen naturgesetze
eine gewisse anzahl an schwingungen der
elektronen von einem atom wie zum
beispiel cäsium gilt hier als eine
sekunde
da diese schwingung mit mehr oder
weniger fest in der natur verankert sind
stellen sie eine sehr verlässliche
quelle für berechnungen da solche
atomuhren liegen tatsächlich erst alle
1,4 millionen jahre um nur eine sekunde
falsch wenn du jetzt auf der erde mit
einem gps zum beispiel mit dem handy
durch die gegend läuft dann empfängt das
gerät konstant die uhrzeit einiger
satelliten oben in der erdumlaufbahn
anhand der verzögerung zwischen dem
verschicken die signale und deren
empfangen kann das gps dann genau
herausfinden wo auf dem planeten du dich
jetzt gerade befindest eine weniger
herkömmliche methode wären wiederum die
sogenannten gravy meter diese geräte
können verwendet werden um die schwere
beschleunigung besser bekannt als
schwerkraft an verschiedenen
geografischen orten zu bestimmen
die schwerkraft der erde ist nämlich
nicht immer gleich sondern überall ein
klein wenig anders
dank des klimawandels und der
schmelzenden eisschichten verteilt sich
aktuell tatsächlich so viel neue masse
in den ozeanen dass sich das kurdische
gravitationsfeld messbar verändert
in diesen gravy metern wird die
sensitivität der quantenteilchen
gegenüber der gravitation ausgenutzt so
genannte atom interferometer können hier
für die welleneigenschaften der
quantenmechanik nutzen um präzise
messungen der gravitation anzustellen
die funktionsweise des ganzen ist dem
doppelspiel experiment aus meinem ersten
video tatsächlich ziemlich ähnlich
dieses experiment ist immerhin quasi
einen atom interferometer anhand der
interferenzen also den überlagerungen
der wellen zweier teilchen können
effekte aus der umgebung abgelesen
werden wie zb eben auch die gravitation
einige forscher der nasa haben sogar
bereits ein gabi meter entwickelt mit
welchem sie die struktur innerhalb von
planeten monden und asteroiden
untersuchen wollen in der zukunft
erwarten uns also dank der quanten
sensorik so einige wissenschaftliche und
damit letztendlich auch technologische
durchbrüche
man könnte beispielsweise die endlichen
ressourcen unseres planeten wie öl und
gas bekommen überwachen oder noch
präzisere navigation ermöglichen
natürlich könnte solche sensorik auch in
der medizin einige anwendungsgebiete
finden
sensible implantate wie
herzschrittmacher und generell genauere
überwachung der körperfunktionen könnten
auf den markt kommen
eines steht fest der beweis der existenz
von gravitationswellen oder die
genaueste berechnung unserer uhrzeiten
ist gerade einmal der anfang
das hier war das fünfte video meiner
serie zum thema quanten in kooperation
mit dem bundesministerium für bildung
und forschung vielen dank für die
unterstützung und vielen dank fürs
zuschauern ich hoffe ich konnte euch die
super spannende welt der quanten ein
bisschen mehr bringen bleibt wie immer
neugierig wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal ein zettel
[Musik]